the jurogan experience so here's venice
beach look at this video
this is uh i mean this is very mild in
comparison to some of the videos that
i've seen
yeah but uh there's one from downtown
l.a
that literally so venice beach all the
boardwalk that whole area
is now just encampments well yeah like
wilshire and
uh san bernardino it's pretty bad right
it's terrible yeah i've seen terrible
wilshire and san vicente is bad downtown
la is absolutely the worst downtown la
is bananas
thousands and thousands of tents and i
don't know how they're gonna put that
genie back in the bottle
and now you've got they're trying to
clean up because they're trying to like
go this is a health hazard
you've got like human [ __ ] in the
streets like how do we clean this so
they're trying to clean up
right now activists are stopping them
from cleaning up they're like your
actions are violence and they're
holding hands and blocking cleanup crews
like
but think about how many more people
you've just added
to the homeless roles because of all the
industries
that have been shut down yeah and people
that can't feed their families
yeah that's the hard part it's like you
know
john we all know the same people and i
actually um
i actually in my heart of hearts think
that
they are they believe that they're
helping
that that's my that's my my belief
that's cute and i just
it is and i know that but but
i'm going to give them the benefit of
doubt that doesn't mean i agree with
them or agree with what they're doing
in the least but i will give a shout out
to like the city of west hollywood
the mayor lindsey vogereth paul aravalo
they have been
so business friendly they're trying to
help as much as they can they
the permits the the ability for me to to
get my patio up and running
they they moved in lightning speed but
i'll give you an example i got the front
patio built
it finished on a friday and on saturday
i got shut down it's worthless
so what did i just spend 60 grand
there's no evidence
that shows that outdoor dining is
contributing significantly to the covett
spread there's no evidence
they actually had to admit that finally
in the in court the county has no
evidence of a nexus
between any sort of outbreak uh
with outdoor dining and how so how do
they make this arbitrary distinct
distinction between outdoor dining and
going to walmart or
like what they're calling essential they
don't it doesn't
so the county health officials
shot us down right for three weeks uh
right around what was it thanksgiving
yes and um some friends of ours
took them to court and said you know how
can you just
shut down an industry with no evidence
and they said oh we have plenty of
evidence we have
six studies and blah blah blah blah and
then they actually got to court
and they had nothing nothing no all the
evidence was from indoor dining
not one piece of paper they had to admit
it so when they admit it then what
happened
no but now they're appealing it that's
why now they're appealing
by the way they've hired an outside
counsel and you're saying
people have our best intentions come on
these guys aren't too nice this guy
newsom wants a name for himself and no
one's calling him out
and it's absolutely insane to me okay
here's the number one thing that
boggles my mind you have a problem
we all agree there's an illness okay
the rates of hospitalizations are going
up infections are going up
but the rates of death are going down
okay so
we have an issue why not get together as
a community and say you know what we're
going to grab
a couple of restaurant people we're
gonna grab some doctors in the field
have a committee and have people that
have
real world experience not phds not
theoretical people people that have real
experience
in the industry grab them grab a round
table and say okay
we have this problem how do we mitigate
it and how do we move forward smartly
i've never been asked john's never been
asked no doctor that i know
in the wide variety of people that i
take care of has ever been asked
their opinion by the county state on any
level
he's right it's it's that's the problem
and i reached out directly i have
uh garcetti's email i emailed this mayor
puts me on with some some random person
from the office that puts me on with the
county and i say hey get us together
like why don't you actually talk to real
restaurant owners this is when they were
thinking about this is when they were
going to do the curfew
right there was a 10 p.m curfew and i
said where is it where's the 10 p.m
curfew come from oh
well when people get inebriated they get
looser and then they're super spreaders
at restaurants and i'm like okay why 10
p.m like that's that's the time when
people really start
start getting inebriated and i was like
but you realize you could at least say
hey
close up let people make sure they get
out and get their check
paid and be out the door by midnight 11
30 whatever it might be
rather than everyone out the door by 10
p.m
he said well you could seat someone at
nine and then kick them out at 9 50
and i was like look have you any do you
have any understanding of the restaurant
industry at all
not one had not contacted any any
restaurateur
they went to a 10 p.m curfew three days
later
shut it all down i just said you know
what we're just shutting everything by
the way
for no reason they've never heard no
from anyways you want to do
six people or less okay you want tables
six feet apart
okay you want to do uh an 11 o'clock
curfew
okay a ten o'clock curfew okay we we've
said yes to
everything they've wanted and yet they
still find a way
yep to shut the industry down well why
this is what i understand
why who's making the decisions i
personally think
again i don't think craig wants wants to
say this but i
personally think it is politicians
trying to make a name for themselves
how does it make a name for you but i
think it's true they are honestly they
think it's fear
what i think it's fear that they're
gonna that they're gonna be seen
as not having done something everything
people are being
you know newsom is on the news
almost every day so much so that people
get get get off get off the news man
like this guy is speaking ever left and
right
he really thinks that he's the savior
situation and i think
that is where it's it's some sort of
political gain situation
in his mind and it's control
like look they're they're explaining by
the way i just found out recently and
we've been i've been this business for
15 years
i had no idea that our indep were
considered independent restaurants
not franchise we had no representation
we had no lobbyists
the the representation for the
restaurant community
is driven by big fast food chains well
they have no incentive to help
independent restaurants you know
mcdonald's and all these people which
god bless them but they're thriving in
covid so
we just get bullied around essentially
because there's no lobbyists
and so we're kind of like sitting ducks
in this situation
and i kind of feel like we're somewhat
trying to be a voice here
for the independent restaurant world and
it's not just la i mean think
think about it's much bigger new york
and la were
we trendsetters right the country
watched what happened in la and new york
and they followed
and now la and new york have just
completely dropped the ball
and everybody else is kind of rising up
well they're examples of government
overreach
their example government overreach
without any thought whatsoever to these
independent businesses
it's a slippery slope yeah how how much
more is that going to happen that is a
big fear well it's also slippery slope
because
what happens if it doesn't come back
what happens if you drive down melrose
and those things stay boarded up
what happens if downtown l.a stays
filled with tents
yep what do you do well how many how
many restaurants are going to be able to
come back i mean like i said right
before we're
we'll manage we'll figure out a way and
and and
john's point like governor newsom
actually did help with something i was
trying to get you know a back patio done
and there were a couple of health
department rules and
and his office did step in and said
that's ridiculous you should
allow that make that happen and they
changed a rule um
that that benefited not just my
restaurant but all right big newsome fan
over here
no no i'm just trying to like i'm trying
to i'm trying to split the difference
like i want i want it to be an honest
conversation of
i think your policies are wrong i don't
dislike you as a person
right that there's a big distinction
sure okay so that's that's all i'm
trying to say
but i will say that uh you know
on the reservation list um
somebody's name that rhymes with
spaghetti will not get a reservation
okay well i'll i'll do that i mean i
will say
i've spoken out about him and we got
targeted pretty hardcore openly
they targeted you they came health came
every night when i finally could
where are the permits for al fresco
where is this every single night i'm
like you were here last night
well you know we we were instructed to
come every night i said okay that means
instructed everything that's what we
know because that's what this is out
against garcetti
and newsome correct jesus [ __ ] christ
and and my my thing is i agree it's
nothing personal
i i it's their policies their arbitrary
policies how does it make sense
that you know there's a million people
passing through tsa a day i looked up
all the stats
how does it make sense that we can fly
here for example
anywhere austin new york whatever it
might be and go right back in the same
day
with zero zero issues zero checks zero
anything
yet outdoor dining is completely shut
down by the way this is the first time
in nine months i've left l.a yeah
and and the only reason the way i got
down here through jet edge by the way
thank you for a great ride and there you
go
and you guys are the best you should
you're a big baller you should use jet
edge
um but i'm flying back to united tonight
and and
you know it's the first time in nine
months that i've left l.a
um and i'm not a science denier and i
take precautions and i'm around
a lot of people when the when the pati
was open i was around 150 180 people a
night
but you can go from la to new york
you can take your mask down and eat you
can land in la
you can go in a hotel you can then go to
a mall and go
shopping okay you can grab some food to
go
we could sit together and eat outdoors
in the mall
but i can't go outdoor and eat at a
restaurant
at that employs 90 to 100 people
and keep a business afloat we're not
thriving
you know outdoor dining doesn't doesn't
it isn't blowing the doors off of the
revenue
it allows us to keep all of the people
employed it allows
employees to make some money we're
paying payroll taxes
we're paying sales taxes and we're just
one little place
there's 30 000 restaurants in los
angeles now
one of the reasons they decided for
shutting it down was
they found that 10 of the restaurants
weren't abiding by the rules
so well i would say then then why don't
you go to those 10
restaurants and shut them down or give
them warnings to the point where they do
come into line so
if they're not social distancing and
they're not wearing masks and shields
and they're not wearing gloves and
they're not doing all the things that
you've asked restaurants to do
well then you can target them but to
shoot to shut down
an entire industry because you feel like
you have a couple of bad actors
makes no sense catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience